hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what is your name saying coop coop
Curtin Cooper Hardin is here finally got
you on the channel didn't working at
this for years I was in a short film I
had a small role in it the star of the
short film though is sitting right here
it's called Civil Defence Red Rover the
film makers and Cooper specially put a
lot of hard work into this short it came
out great so many of you guys have
already gone over to go check it out
thank you so much for doing it more of
you guys should go be checking it out
because she's amazing in it the whole
thing turned out really good civil
offense Red Rover and the multi house
entertainment YouTube channel please go
check it out as soon as you can
otherwise Cooper will not return if you
wanted her return you gotta go check it
out tough girl I like pulse right now
you're making my like heart rates bye
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
guys we're gonna watch today 10
inappropriate scenes in Disney films
I've seen other videos that do like
breakdowns of inappropriate moments but
I'm about specifically Disney we're
Disney Plus now out we should go after
you know what have they unintentionally
done that is inappropriate you excited
for this Cooper oh yeah yeah an
appropriate theme yeah
[Laughter]
we are parents and adults make it as
much fun out of Disney and Pixar movies
as kids but everyone assumes that the
actual stories in humor won't be
anything to achieve for younger
audiences but sometimes the people
actually making the movie just can't
help themselves sliding in crude jokes
are addled gags that can't be unseen and
are almost guaranteed to have older
viewers laughing and wondering how they
could have ever missed them the first
time in some cases you won't even
believe these things there are some
adult jokes that go over kids heads yes
then there are the ones that are subtle
enough to even be missed by parents in
Toy Story 3 the gang learns just how
rude the villain Lotso really is when
you post off the mouths of mrs. Potato
Head Oh mr. Potato Head let's Lotso know
that only her husband is allowed to pull
that dr. aamil Anatomy did not a massive
bruise swelling on the top of his head
the suggestive shape of his skull but
when trying to explain the tiny little
truth he's hiding it's impossible to
miss Colette's grimace and quick glance
below and wienies waist it's a joke
aimed squarely at older fans
ah slipping some slides humor into found
the entertainment although Bambi is the
surgery his good friend flower the skunk
is just as memorable
when flower first runs into Bluebell the
pair share a kiss that renders him
completely Rose it's a cute and harmless
joke but once people realize a kiss made
flower flush with blood and grow as
stiff as a board to shake the young
sports car is realize that your decision
to show their high beams to the racer
actually means that I'll take that yeah
surprisingly that's not even the only
adult joke made in the manner a later
scene shows a roadside restaurant called
the top-down truck stop in case audience
members didn't get the reference the
sign also advertises all convertible
waitresses that's right I've taught this
truck stop right under but the writers
couldn't resist making one tiny joke
given the city's famous history in the
gay rights movement when emotions run
wild upon seeing the new house fear
wonders if any deadly bears live in the
city with anger claiming to have seen
one already it's not really very good
you look
the line is meaningless to kids but
adults will realize the term is
typically used in the gay community to
describe large hairy men had no idea so
the two straight to home video sequels
that follow the original we're no
surprise but apparently the studio
figured nobody was paying attention by
the third in the series finally set to
get married a sudden attack on the
castle gives Jeanne the opening for one
of his signature one-liners wasn't
supposed to move until the honeymoon
making a sex joke about the young couple
wasn't too inappropriate but it shows
just how much can slip by a nose ah I
would like to get in that chair I still
don't get it that's just the shake until
honeymoon capping in an extremely small
tent when audiences realized they're
watching as he pitches a tent and fight
to his crotch love could have any crew
to it right when on a first joins forces
with Christoph he's less than supportive
about her marrying a man she just met
you mean to tell me you got engaged to
someone you just met that day you think
it's a bad move by quizzing her with
questions about Hans including his foot
size obviously on the idea that the size
doesn't matter when it comes to a man's
don't mansplain woman's thoughts for
more videos like this
some of these are great and other ones
were like I gotta say some before we
talk about this video before we film I
always try to get height adjustments
with whatever I'm on camera with I
reject this the seats and like a were
their position dad and everything so
that way the video is in a certain frame
and then we're in the right position
I've never had a first time guest on
this channel ever it gets so comfortable
filming you guys couldn't see this but
she was like she was just like back here
oh no like I'm really careful
sue me I don't like it yeah no you're
gonna sue me remember so now it's just a
moot point now it's a callback the mrs.
Potato Head mouth seriously some of
these he was really reaching because I'm
like Toy Story is not employing just for
this guy in general he had to go back
and watch all these movies for some of
these talent it's a present I'm pretty
impressed I had a lot of those things
flew over my head well the thing with
the mrs. Potato Head me okay I don't
think the movies making the joke but
with like removing a mouth and certain
toys you can get at certain stores that
are mouth shaped Cooper ugh and I don't
know why yeah I do
there's no benefit
[Music]
my wife I thought it was the centaur
head in it so the priest has a boner
getting married yeah that's the one I
actually think that might have been I
think he was kind of yeah myself the
Bambi blush honks yes God's the skirts
you look if you read into it yeah yeah
if you read into it but also like I
don't know your dude don't you don't you
get all like hot inside and like
blushing like how the animated his
reaction yeah yeah always like gotta be
more than like well I wonder if back
then
that was because there was so old like
yeah they making those kind of jokes
loud yeah but I think nowadays audiences
could see that movie you know that's how
guys talking detail the cars convertible
waitress one I think is a brilliant one
the flashing headlights the flashing
headlights one exactly that is I think
intentionally planted there and if you
read into it you'll get it well you'll
get and it's like it's smart smart
that's how they get the adults to go
exactly yes look out for Easter eggs
this is what we do yeah the emperor's
new group one with the tent over this
watch was clever I don't know if that
was like an intentional joke well why
did he have a tent over his garage
protect you're good at justifying I
appreciate this
[Laughter]
do women ever say the foot size thing as
a way to think in junior high as a
comparison my confidence would be so
much bigger what size thing was accurate
this is how I talk myself no it matters
yes there's no it's just to eat your own
to each everyone's own you know you just
find what fits it doesn't matter how
many women say that every guy still I
feel like when guys are growing up
playing sports and they had their
communal showers right like y'all would
compare it was like a thing it's like I
had friends that told me they did that I
didn't play on teams that I was an altar
server okay
[Music]
all right this is a great first video
Cooper well well you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification belly and notify we got
video up all the Cooper on Instagram
people
she's always dressed in full on tuxedos
the way men love to see a woman and go
check out the civil defense red rubber
short film by Dennis with a page of the
day shot to a woman named Jen Smith now
Jen you have a little boy and I'm sure
you show him a lot of Disney movies so I
would just precondition him now that
whenever you're watching a Disney movie
with him to point out all the sexual
inappropriate moments for him because
when your boy goes to school and points
this out to all his friends
boom popular all's good exactly he's
exactly then and also if you want him to
get a girlfriend or boyfriend I don't
know how you're raising it but whichever
right putting down I'm telling you that
kind of observational skills will earn
in brownie points cuz what more do kids
love about you anyway Jen I love you
Jenna gonna watch this I'll talk to you
I hope everything's going well in school
and everything and yeah much love and
thank you for being here Jennifer
say Thank You Cooper Thank You Jennifer
Smith
[Laughter]
you